miles de dolientes citas salieron a las
calles desde irán hasta yemen cuando se
cumple un año del asesinato del veterano
general qasem soleimani líder de las
fuerzas de élite al quds de la guardia
revolucionaria islámica iraní en un
ataque con drones estadounidenses una
muestra de condena a los calificados de
ocupantes americanos que congregó
masivas marchas en irak
nuestra participación hoy es para marcar
y condenar lo que el enemigo sionista
americano hizo cuando atacó a los
líderes los líderes de la victoria que
por ellos y su sangre en nuestra tierra
fue liberada y a través de este canal
pedimos al gobierno iraquí que tome una
posición firme para exigir el castigo de
las personas que mataron a estos líderes
victoriosos de las distintas
conmemoraciones por los comandantes que
se vienen celebrando durante todo el fin
de semana entre la comunidad musulmana
chiíta vuelve a aumentar las tensiones
regionales que en materia internacional
marcarán el último tramo de donald trump
en la casa blanca irán acusó a israel de
planear ataques contra intereses
estadounidenses en la región para
provocar una guerra algo que israel
desmintió y calificó de señalamientos
sin sentido
de la muerte de soleimán y coincide con
el anuncio de teherán de intensificar
sus planes nucleares con el
enriquecimiento de uranio al 20% y
washington aparentemente se prepara para
la posibilidad de represalias
basándonos en nuestra experiencia el
martirio de cualquier líder de la
resistencia ha fortalecido la presencia
y las raíces de la resistencia ahora
surjan watán luján irán y eeuu enemigos
acérrimos desde la revolución islámica
iraní en 1979 han estado dos veces al
borde del conflicto desde junio de 2019
una relación que empeoró con el
asesinato de soleimani y el cada vez más
debilitado factor nuclear
[Música]